bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en direct sur notre
antenne à la séance de questions cribles
thématiques consacrées cet après-midi et
la gynécologie médicale les sénateurs
ont donc une heure pour interroger
marisol touraine à la ministre de la
santé
il faut dire que cette spécialité de la
gynécologie médicale et bien souffre
d'une véritable pénurie
cela permet donc de ne plus assurer un
suivi de qualité pour toutes les femmes
les sénateurs s'inquiètent donc de la
disparition de cette spécialité c'est un
recul pour la société et une mise en
danger pour la santé des femmes
les sénateurs souhaitent donc savoir
quelles sont les mesures que compte
prendre le gouvernement pour mettre un
terme à cette situation tout de suite
donc direction à l'hémicycle pour cette
séance de questions cribles bonne après
midi à toussieu le président madame la
ministre
la gynécologie médicale est une
spécialité de notre système de santé à
laquelle les femmes françaises sont très
attachés puisque 60% d'entre elles
consultent régulièrement un ou une
gynécologue
ces professionnels assurent une prise en
charge des femmes tout au long de leur
vie pour les questions relatives à la
contraception l'obstétrique les ist
l'éducation à la sexualité et la
prévention la ménopause les dépistages
de concerts l'accompagnement des couples
infertiles les pma etc etc
leur complémentarité avec les
chirurgiens gynécologues les
obstétriciens les sages femmes les
médecins généralistes et les pharmaciens
assure un maillage pertinent au service
de la santé des femmes
après la réforme de l'internât de 80
1984 la gynécologie médicale a été
supprimé du cursus universitaire cette
décision a entraîné la forte
mobilisation que l'on sait pour demander
son maintien
cette discipline a été rétablie en 2003
par la création du drs
de gynéco médicale toutefois la
situation nous oblige à la vigilance
puisque le nombre de gynécologues
médicaux formés ne suffit pas à
compenser les départs en retraite
prévisible et on sait que d'ici 2020
presque 60% d'entre eux partiront à la
retraite
les organisations professionnelles
demande d'ouverture de 40 postes
d'internât par an au lieu de 30
aujourd'hui ainsi que la construction de
véritables parcours hospitalo
universitaires pour donner à cette
discipline toute son importance au sein
du système de santé
alors à l'heure où des questions de
santé publique apparaissent sur
certaines pilules contraceptives cette
spécialité médicale représente une
sécurité auprès des femmes pour peut
évidemment qu'on vérifie son
indépendance vis-à-vis des laboratoires
madame la ministre comment envisagez
vous la question du renouvellement des
gynécologues médicaux pour compenser le
nom de nombreux départs en retraite et
ne pensez vous pas envisageable de
confier à ces professionnels un rôle de
santé publique comme ressource auprès de
l'ensemble des prescripteurs de leur
territoire en termes de conseil
d'information de formation ou de gestion
de forums des changes par notamment
merci merci pour vous répondre la parole
et à madame barrisol touraine ministres
affaires sociales et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je voudrais commencer par dire que la
santé des femmes
cela concerne la moitié de la population
française est donc évidemment on ne peut
pas au moins on ne peut donc pas
considérer que ce soit un enjeu mineur
pour notre système de santé et vous avez
raison de souligner que dans notre pays
les femmes sont particulièrement
attachés à la gynécologie médicale à
leur gynécologue elles sont 93% a
exprimé le souhait de pouvoir consulter
pour ce qui est de leur dépistage des
conseils gynécologique un spécialiste en
gynécologie médicale c'est une
spécialité qui renvoie à l'intimé et
donc c'est une demande une inspiration
des femmes à laquelle je suis sensible
et je veux dire que ma volonté de faire
en sorte que
les femmes françaises puissent disposer
de la possibilité d'accéder lorsqu elle
le souhaite et si elles le souhaitent à
un gynécologue médical or nous sommes
vous l'avez indiqué confronté à un
problème de démographie puisque 78% des
gynécologues médicaux ont plus de 55 ans
contre 40 2% seulement des autres
spécialistes ce qui marque un enjeu
important pour les années à venir nous
en sommes là parce qu entre 1984 et 2003
on a arrêté de former des gynécologues
médicaux et donc la première mesure à
prendre c'est de consolider le drs de
gynécologie médicale en tant que
spécialité médicale à part entière et
c'est la raison pour laquelle madame la
sénatrice j'ai retiré le projet de
décret qui visait à rendre automatique
l'agrément pour la gynécologie médicale
des services de gynécologie obstétrique
je le dis la spécialité de gynécologie
médicale doit être reconnu à part
entière et cela implique des mesures
fortes en la matière c'est nous voulons
que la démographie médicale soit à la
hauteur des attentes des françaises dans
les années à venir
merci chers collègues vous avez unis
militent pour réagir aux propos du
ministre
oui mais c'est président madame la
ministre je suis ravi d'entendre ces
réponses merci pour les précisions que
vous nous avez donné
et puis cette volonté d'inscrire la
gynécologie médicale dans un parcours et
un paysage de santé publique conviendra
tout à fait comme vous l'avez dit à une
grande partie de la population et
notamment toutes ces femmes qui ont
recours à elle je vous remercie madame
la ministre
merci la parole est à présent à madame
laurence cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen madame la ministre
je me réjouis que notre groupe est
proposée à la conférence des présidents
une séance de questions cribles sur la
gynécologie médicale et j'apprécie déjà
les réponses que vous avez apporté à ma
collègue comme elle l'a dit d'ailleurs
cette spécialité a connu entre 87 et
2003 17 ans de non recrutement
conduisant au tarissement de l'offre de
soins destination des femmes
voire dans certains départements et
selon les années à une disparition
totale
pourtant la gynécologie médicale parce
que c'est une spécialité dédié aux
femmes comme vous l'avez souligné à tous
les stades de leur vie parce que ne se
réduit ni à l'accouchement ni à la
chirurgie est une spécialité
indispensable pour les femmes
je dois dire qu'elle est essentiellement
préventive et permet tout à la fois la
réduction des risques et par conséquent
la baisse de certaines dépenses de santé
liées à un traitement pris tardivement
dans l'intérêt des femmes et de la
société toute entière il est donc
impératif que le nom d'un terme en
gynécologie médicale corresponde
réellement aux besoins des femmes or
l'année dernière seuls 30 postes ont été
créés soit le même nombre de postes que
s'est ouvert l'année précédente
et j'aurais soulignait ce propos que
dans mon département le val de marne
selon l'atlas de démographie médicale
rendue publique par le conseil national
de l'ordre des médecins
cela a conduit à une diminution de
l'ordre de 9% de gynécologues médicaux
et le nombre de nouveaux installés est
inférieur comme celle là était dit par
michel au nombre de départs à la
retraite dans les jours à venir vous
aurez à déterminer les postes internes à
ouvrir pour l'année 2013-2014
aussi madame la ministre pourriez-vous
nous informer dès aujourd'hui du nombre
de postes d'internés que vous entendez
créé afin de répondre aux besoins réels
des femmes et voir par votre
intervention comment aider les ars à
prendre les bonnes décisions
merci merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice laurence cohen
de nouveau je voudrais insister sur
l'importance de la relation entre les
femmes et les gynécologues médicale
d'ailleurs c'est une profession qui est
très féminisée 70% des gynécologues
médicales sont des femmes et cela
explique aussi la nature de la relation
est latente que les femmes ont envers
leur médecin vous avez raison d'insister
sur le fait que l'on a cessé de former
des gynécologues médical pendant plus de
faim environ 10 ans ce qui contribue à
la difficulté démographique à laquelle
nous sommes
confronté pour l'année universitaire
2011-2012 on compte 80 un interne en
gynécologie médicale dont 20 seulement
en dernière année d'internât
en 2004 date de la création du diplôme
d'études spécialisées de gynécologie
médicale 16 place d'un terne était
offerte à l'examen classant national 16
place en 2004 en 2012 j'ai demandé
l'ouverture de 30 places afin d'engager
un renouveau et une remontée des
propositions les simulations
démographique dont nous disposons
montrent en effet qu'il faut 45 à 50
places à l'examen classant national pour
maintenir une densité de gynécologie
médicale raisonnable c'est-à-dire qu'ils
correspondent à l'existence de cette a8
gynécologues médicaux pour cent mille
femmes de 15 ans ou plus j'ai donc
demandé au président de l'observatoire
national de la démographie des
professions de santé
une attention particulière dans cette
dans l'évaluation régional des besoins
je lui ai demandé de poursuivre le
renforcement de la gynécologie médicale
d'augmenter le nombre de places d'ici
l'objectif étant bien d'arriver à 45
place à l'examen classant national en
2016 merci madame laurence cohen
madame la ministre que vous partagiez
donc notre notre souci est que vous ayez
pris les premières mesures qui vont dans
le bon sens je me permets d'insister
auprès de vous pour vraiment y ait un
réel un réel suivi parce que les
chiffres qui nous remontent drs sont
parfois étonnants par exemple en
auvergne il n'y aurait pas lieu d'ouvrir
des postes alors qu'il n'ya que 0.5
gynécologues médicaux pour 5000 femmes
et je vous rappelle qu'il y en aurait
0,8 en ile-de-france donc voilà un peu
méfiante sur les chiffres il faut donc
qu'il y ait vraiment une intervention
politique comme vous le
vous semblez le partager et aussi faire
fi des des arguments qui tendent à
montrer qu'il y aurait une insuffisance
des terrains de stage en chu en chu
alors que l'on sait qu'il qu'ils doivent
être nécessairement pourvus donc voilà
j'attire à nouveau votre attention je
crois que la politique qui kim qui a été
menée par les plus tôt la pratique des
gynécologues médicaux à montrer que
c'est pas un hasard que dans notre pays
il ya un recul notamment de tout ce qui
est cancer du sein de l'utérus donc tout
ça c'est pas un hasard donc il faut
vraiment poursuivre dans une voie
beaucoup plus audacieuse en ce sens où
il faut qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
praticiens donc nous comptons sur vous
merci pour la question suivante la
parole est pas madame aline archimbaud
pour le groupe écologiste
mais ce président un madame la ministre
les difficultés de la gynécologie
médicale décrite par mes collègues à
l'instant et je me réjouis des premières
réponses que vous avez apporté ces
difficultés sont symptomatiques d'un
problème plus large
c'est en fait la suffisante prise en
considération de la spécificité du corps
des femmes par la médecine qui est une
activité dont la pratique est la
recherche ont été longtemps
exclusivement du domaine des hommes l'un
des faits les plus marquants par exemple
c'est qu'un bon nombre de prescriptions
médicales destinées aux femmes reposent
en fait sur des essais entièrement
conduit sur des hommes ou des animaux
mal leurs spécificités plutôt que d'être
prises en compte
exclu les femmes de ses excès de ces
essais cliniques que les variations de
leur cycle hormonal conflit fixe irait
donc rendrait plus coûteux 79% des
antidouleurs ne sont ainsi testé que sur
des hommes ou des animaux mal et même
quand il s'agit d'étudier des
pathologies reconnues comme infectant
différemment les deux sexes la parité
n'est pas respectée la majorité des
anxiolytiques sont par exemple très peu
testé sur les femmes alors qu'elles ont
deux points 25 fois plus de problèmes
d'anxiété que les hommes
c'est donc dans ce contexte général que
nous constatons l'insuffisance du nombre
de postes
gynécologie médicale ouvert chaque année
à l'internât de médecine surtout
lorsqu'on les compare au nombre de
départs en retraite cela a été souligné
par exemple sur les 875 gynécologue
exerçant aujourd'hui en ile de france
soit une moyenne de 0,8 pour 5000 femmes
en âge de consulter 48%
c'est à dire pratiquement la moitié vont
partir en retraite dans les cinq ans et
vous le savez cette spécialité médicale
est est la seule à suivre les femmes
d'un bout à l'autre de leur vie c'est
notamment grâce à la gynécologie
médicale que le pays connaît une
espérance de vie record des femmes en
particulier du fait d'un dépistage
précoce des cancers féminins et d'un
suivi de la qualité de la contraception
en conséquence ces difficultés d'accès à
une consultation régulière de
gynécologie médicale pose des problèmes
croissants de suivi des femmes et donc
de prévention ce qui constitue un risque
pour leur santé ce qui est source de
fortes inégalités et ceux qui de
surcroît pèsera à long terme sur nos
finances publiques madame la ministre
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour remédier à ces problèmes
merci madame marisol touraine
si monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice aline archimbaud je veux vous
dire toute l'importance que j'accorde à
la prise en compte de la spécificité des
paramètres de santé des déterminants de
santé pour les femmes
en ce qui concerne la démographie
médicale je veux redire ma détermination
puisqu'il y avait en 2011 27 postes
ouverts en gynécologie médicale à
l'examen classant national 30 en 2013
alors que les propositions qui m'avaient
été faites et est de maintenir ce nombre
à 27 je le redis augmentation à 30 et
perspectives de 45 en 2016 au-delà de
ces éléments quantitatifs madame
archambault il est vrai que nous sommes
confrontés au fait que la santé des
femmes
aujourd'hui est confrontée à des défis
de plus en plus important puisque les
femmes étaient jusqu'à maintenant
protégé de certaines maladies
compte tenu des comportements plus
vertueux entre guillemets qu'elle
pouvait avoir mais nous voyons désormais
qu'alors que le cancer du poumon
exemple régresse chez les hommes il
augmente de façon très significative
chez les femmes puisqu'elles se sont
mises à fumer nous voyons que healy a
désormais des pathologies auxquelles il
faut répondre qu'ils sont tout à fait
préoccupante
nous constatons aussi qu'il y à un
renoncement aux soins et à la prévention
plus fréquent chez les femmes puisque
plus de 16% des femmes renoncent aux
soins contre 11% seulement des sommes
qu'ils renoncent aux soins ce qui est
préoccupant
pour ce qui est des essais cliniques qui
convient davantage réalisés sur les
femmes
deux éléments que je souhaite porter à
votre connaissance le premier c'est que
nous devons être attentifs au fait que
des échecs certains essais cliniques ne
peuvent pas être réalisées sur des
femmes en âge de procréer puisque il
faut prendre des précautions pour le cas
où ces femmes de se re est enceinte ce
qui constitue une limite dont nous
devons tenir compte pour autant nous
devons être attentifs à mieux prendre en
compte la spécificité des femmes à
travers des protocoles d'essais
cliniques concernant les femmes les
décisions doivent se prendre au niveau
européen la france avec d'autres états
mais la france est fortement engagé en
la matière et nous avons obtenu un
conseil européen en matière de santé qui
se tiendra le 28 juin prochain et qui
portera notamment sur les conditions
permettant la réalisation plus facile
d'essais cliniques sur les femmes madame
lennard chenault je vous remercie madame
la ministre de vaud de vos engagements
et des décisions que vous avez prises
comme vous l'avez dit vous-même nous
partons de loin et c'est vrai que qu'il
faudra du temps et
et la détermination dans la durée pour
retrouver une situation à peu près
correct il se trouve c'est le hasard que
je visitais ce matin centre de santé à
saint denis dans une ville de cent mille
habitants
il reste une seule gynécologue médical
l'autre étant parti à la retraite il ya
peu c'est un exemple alors il a
certainement cumul de différentes
inégalités sociales territoriales qui
s'ajoute mais voilà c'est vrai que nous
partons noah je vous remercie en tout
cas de de prendre le problème à bras le
corps et et de prendre des décisions
fortes dans ce domaine merci la parole
est à présent à monsieur le président
yvon collin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen merci monsieur le président
madame un d'un ministre mes chers
collègues les menaces qui pèsent sur
l'avenir de la gynécologie médicale
pourrait fragiliser toute la politique
de santé menée à l'égard des femmes et
ce depuis des décennies dans notre pays
les résultats obtenus grâce à un suivi
médical régulier et de qualité sont tout
à fait remarquables
par exemple dans 20 ans le nombre de
cancers du col de l'utérus a été divisé
par quatre
et la mortalité par deux j'ajouterai que
les françaises ont une des meilleure
survie à 5 ans du cancer du sein la
gynécologie médicale fortement
préventive est au coeur de la réussite
de la politique de santé des femmes et
pourtant pourtant l'existence de cette
spécialité est menacée nous assistons
sur notre territoire une véritable
pénurie des génies colog en particulier
en zone rurale
une fois de plus d'amendés partir de
tarn-et-garonne ida seulement deux
praticiens exerçant la gynécologie
médicale soit 1 26 pour cent pour cent
mille femmes et la moyenne de la région
se situe en à 6,2 pour cent mille femmes
avec une très forte concentration dans
l'agglomération toulousaine
à ce propos nos collègues avaient mort
et jean luc fichet ont remis la semaine
dernière leur excellent rapport sur les
airs médicaux ils ont très bien décrit
cette problématique touche toutes les
spécialités
mais s'agissant de la gynécologie
médicale il faut garder à l'esprit un
handicap supplémentaire l'absence de
diplôme en deux entre 1990 et 2003 ne
fut pas sans conséquences
les effective cette spécialité alors
accumulé un retard que le numerus
clausus limitée à 30 aujourd'hui ne
permettra pas de combler madame la
ministre la santé des femmes est en
danger si vous n'intervenez pas
notamment sur ce numerus clausus ma
question est donc simple
que comptez-vous faire et comment le
faire je vous remets madame la ministre
vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur comme mieux j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire en réponse à madame cohen
j'ai la volonté très affirmée de faire
en sorte d'une part que soit clairement
reconnu comme spécialité à part entière
la gynécologie médicale et je redis là
que le fait que j'ai refait fait retirer
un projet de décret qui consistait à
donner automatiquement la reconnaissance
en gynécologie médicale à des
gynécologues obstétriciens
comme s'il n'y avait pas de spécificité
dans l'exercice de la gynécologie
médicale et d'autre part cette volonté
qui est la mienne s'exprimer s'est
d'ores et déjà exprimé dans la montée en
puissance du numerus clausus tel qu'il a
été fixé et pour l'année 2012
et pour l'année 2013 est telle que j'ai
demandé qu'il soit travailler et
préparer pour les années à venir
comme je les ai indiqué 27 postes
étaient ouverts en 2011 30 postes ont
été ouverts en 2012 30 postes alors que
il était proposé d'en rester à 27 postes
pour 2013 salir en juin 2013 il y aura
35 postes ouverts à l'examen classant
national donc on voit qu'il y à déjà une
première montée en puissance 35 postes
et j'ai vu avec le président de
l'observatoire des professions de santé
à la manière de monter nous avons
réfléchi ensemble à la façon de faire
monter ce numerus clausus pour qu'ils
atteignent 45 postes ouverts sans doute
en 2016 peut être plus tôt car c'est
avec cette montée en puissance rapide
volontariste et déterminé que nous
serons à même de répondre aux défis que
vous
qui que vous posez qui existe dans les
zones rurales assurément mais aussi dans
les zones urbaines puisque je vous le
rappelle l'âge moyen des gynécologues
médical et de 7 ans supérieure à l'âge
moyen des autres spécialistes et donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un an j'ai un enjeu
et d'un danger un enjeu qui est
particulièrement identifié est important
pour notre pays
merci monsieur yvon collin pour la
ministre monsieur le président merci
madame la mise de votre réponse mais
j'ajouterai notre élément d'inquiétude
qui concerne l'attitude de
l'administration hospitalière
je m'interroge sur une volonté parfois
peine voilée dans les centres
hospitaliers de fermer les consultations
de gynécologie médicale parce que
celle-ci ne s'inscrivent pas bien dans
la démarche de rationalisation des
chouettes la plupart des spécialités
d'une approche centrée sur les organes
aux moyens d'actes techniques leur
coûter tard ainsi quantifiable en
revanche la gynécologie à une approche
globale de la femme faisant intervenir à
la fois le corps biologique le corps
social et le corps affectif ce qui n'est
pas compatible avec la tendance qui
consiste à fragmenter la prise en charge
des patients pour un meilleur contrôle
et souhaite dans une optique d'économie
il faut le reconnaître le cabinet du
génie colog c'est aussi un lieu de
dialogue avec un coût de certes mais qui
peut se révéler in fine et un réel
bénéfice si l'on raisonne en termes
d'itinéraires de santé et ce tout au
long de sa vie soit remercié merci je
passe la parole à présent madame
marie-thérèse bruguière pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous avez pratiquement
répondu à la question que j'allais poser
mais il ya quand même encore quelque
chose que je voudrais éclairé
aujourd'hui en france la france compte
1000 gynécologue et selon les
projections
selon les projections il ne serait que 6
à 1 en 2015 et 181 en 2020 pour le même
nombre de patientes donc les délais pour
obtenir un rendez-vous sont de plus en
plus longs il faut même quelquefois
attendre jusqu'à six mois selon les
territoires
semin que d'effectifs fortement
préjudiciable pour le suivi de la santé
des femmes
d'après les données évidemment de
l'institut national d'études
démographiques 12,2 pour cent des 20 24
ans ont déclaré en 2010
ne pas avoir de suivi habituel contre
6,9 en 2000 pourtant cette spécialité
médicale est la seule qui garantissent
aux femmes un suivi personnalisé
notamment en matière de prévention et de
dépistage de certaines maladies
ce qui fonctionne très bien dans notre
pays en effet le nombre des cancers du
col de l'utérus a été divisée par quatre
en vingt ans on est le pays où il ya
même le moins d'hystérectomie pour le
néo dussaigne une des meilleure survie
en europe 84% de survie à cinq ans alors
pour pallier ce manque d'effectif et
tout à l'heure vous en parliez madame la
ministre
j'ai bien entendu que pour 2013 il y
aurait trois de plus que pour
d'effectifs trois de plus que pour 2010
2015 nous passerions à 35 ce qui
effectivement augmente d'un petit peu
mais c'est peut-être pas encore
suffisant et j'appelle notre attention
qu il ya de plus en plus de jeunes
femmes et de jeunes filles de 14 ans qui
préfère consulter et da de femmes d'âge
mûr qui préfèrent consulter un
gynécologue junicode médical plutôt
qu'un obstétriciens est difficile de se
retrouver un certain âge dans des salles
de cause d'attentes avec des gynécos
avec des femmes enceinte jusqu'aux dame
par ailleurs la loi du 22 juillet 2009
dit elle hpt hspt pardon prévoit de
recourir à des prévisions quinquennales
vous nous avez répondu je vous je vous
en remercie madame la ministre des
années d'action obstiné ont abouti à
l'as à la création le 1er février 2013
d'un diplôme spécifique de gynéco
médicale ces années de combat ont
exprimé de façon éclatante l'attachement
des femmes à cette spécialité sur mesure
pour elle et je dis bien pour elle
aujourd'hui cet attachement demeurent
les femmes d'un âge mûr et je viens de
le dire préfère consulter un médecin je
me répète chacun son champ de compétence
de la même manière que les accouchements
il faut des gynéco obstétricien et des
sages-femmes des puéricultrices pour les
enfants merci madame la ministre m'avoir
écouté je crois que la réponse a déjà
été donnée
c'est pas la peine que vous vous rendiez
merci merci chers collègues je passe
tout de même la parole à madame là
ministre si elle souhaite réagir à mon
univers merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
moi je partage comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire le constat que vous posez
comment en est on arrivé là
parce que un peu d'histoire est utile
c'est madame michèle barzach ministre de
la santé de monsieur du gouvernement
chirac qui en 1986 a supprimé la
spécialité de gynécologie médicale alors
qu'elle même était gynécologue roselyne
bachelot qui a été ministre de la santé
du gouvernement fillon a consacré la fin
la gynécologie médicale en réduisant le
nombre de places à l'examen classant
national et en considérant que cette
spécialité n'avait pas de raison d'être
ce qu'elles donnaient comme
argumentation était que la gynécologie
médicale était de plus en plus
spécialisés devaient se développer dans
le cadre de projets cliniques à
l'hôpital donc renvoyés à des
problématiques très spécifique mais
qu'en ville les fans pouvaient se
tourner vers d'autres types de
professionnels je crois que cette
approche exclusivement hospitalière de
la gynécologie médicale a contribué à
peser sur la démographie des
gynécologues médicaux et a constitué le
problème auquel nous sommes aujourd'hui
collectivement confrontés et donc je
veux indiquer que comme je les ai dit ma
volonté de faire en sorte que les femmes
puissent trouver en ville
un gynécologue médicale parce que c'est
bien cela l'enjeu dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires sous des formes qu'il faut
évidemment organisé et aménagé et avec
les mesures que j'ai commencé à prendre
et bien à la fin de 2016 et dans la
perspective de l'examen classant de 2017
nous devrions considérer que nous aurons
formé 50 % de gynécologues médicaux en
plus que si nous étions restés au nombre
de gynécologues médicaux formé en 2011
il me semble que c'est une étape
volontariste importante qui aura été
franchi
merci chocolat ne voulait prolonger le
jeu vous remercie la parole est à
présent madame la présidente muguette
dini pour le groupe union des démocrates
et indépendants russie merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre chers
collègues beaucoup de question ayant été
posée sur la gynécologie médicale
stricto sensu
je voudrais me situer sur le plan de la
patiente et des obstétriciens
il me semble qu'il serait nécessaire de
clarifier ce qui devient de plus en plus
confus dans l'esprit de la patiente
le rôle de chacun des professionnels de
santé partie prenante de la gynécologie
qui peut re prépare à ces demandes
cette patiente doit elle s'adresser à un
gynécologue médicale libérale à
gynécologue obstétricien libéral ou en
établissement un généraliste ayant fait
un cursus d'un en gynécologie à une sage
femme si elle est enceinte
il me semblerait intéressant que le rôle
spécifique ou complémentaire de chacune
de ces professions soient mieux connus
et plus précis pour une meilleure
compréhension ne devrait-on pas garder
le seul titre d'obstétriciens pour celui
qui pratique les accouchements et opère
en gynécologie par ailleurs si le nombre
d'obstétriciens continue à diminuer de
manière aussi rapide qui assistera les
parturientes qui prendra en charge les
grossesses et les accouchements
pathologique de plus en plus nombreux en
relation avec l'augmentation des
grossesses tardives les services de
maternité sont soumis à des surcroît
d'activité sans augmentation des moyens
équivalents
la diminution du nombre de titres ea
siens ne va-t-elle pas encore accroître
cette surcharge de travail
enfin comment distinguer plus clairement
le gynécologue médicale qui a fait
quatre ans de spécialités du généraliste
qui n'en a fait qu'un je ne poserai pas
ma dernière question sur l'avenir de la
gynécologie médicale parce que madame la
ministre vous y avaient déjà répondu
merci madame la ministre merci monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice le plus
important me semble-t-il est de
déterminer la possibilité ou de garantir
la possibilité pour les femmes d'accéder
à un professionnel de leur choix et à un
professionnel qui soient identifiés
comme pouvant répondre à leurs besoins
il y à des femmes qui se tournent
spontanément et naturellement vers leur
médecin généraliste pour des raisons de
suivi global général d' accompagnement
personnel et cela est très positif
les médecins généralistes sont aussi des
médecins qui apporte l'information le
suivi les actes de prévention
nécessaires en matière de contraception
en matière de suivi de grossesse
il y à des femmes qui souhaitent elles
clairement faire la différence entre
leur suivi médical général et leur suivi
gynécologique elle souhaite voir confier
à un gynécologue médical c'est cela
qu'il s'agit de garantir ce qui revient
à bien permettre la coopération entre
les professionnels et permettre que une
femme puisse le cas échéant être suivis
tout au long d'un parcours coordonné
maîtrisé par exemple si elle attend un
enfant que la grossesse soit identifiées
à la suite d'une consultation chez son
généraliste qu'elles puissent ensuite
aller voir un médecin gynécologue
médical pendant le suivi de sa grossesse
ou une sage-femme et puis ensuite
qu'elles fassent le choix éventuellement
d'un gynécologue obstétricien donc
chaque médecin a une identité
particulière ce qui me semble nécessaire
c'est que la liberté de choix des femmes
soit garanti or c'était cela qui était
menacée le nombre de gynécologues
médicaux diminuant un nombre croissant
de femmes souhaitant accéder à des
gynécologues médicaux n'avaient defacto
plus la possibilité de le faire et donc
c'est cette situation là qu'il s'agit
d'inverser
merci madame muguette dini merci madame
la ministre de votre réponse je ne suis
pas absolument certaine que l'ensemble
des femmes sachent bien faire la
distinction entre le jcall gynécologue
médical et le gynécologue obstétricien
et dans la mesure où ce que disait notre
collègue monsieur colin nous avons
maintenant je crois que c'est monsieur
colin à l'hôpital une manière de dire
que la gynécologie stricto sensu prend
trop de temps
est ce que il n'y aurait pas à faire une
distinction plus précises entre les
gynécologues et les obstétriciens
mais je vous remercie de votre réponse
et dire merci la parole est à présent
monsieur claude jeannerot pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues les français qui nous
regardent sont très attachés à leur
système de santé
mais ils pressentent que seule une
organisation publique de la santé est de
nature à garantir un principe essentiel
ce principe c'est l'égal accès aux soins
pour tous les citoyens et ce droit
universel et précisément n'est pas
toujours effectif et en particulier nous
le savons bien les inégalités
territoriales sont à l'heure et la
désertification médicale dans certaines
zones géographiques est hélas devenu une
réalité
l'organisation de la gynécologie
médicale dans notre pays n'échappe pas à
ce constat d'inégalités beaucoup de mes
collègues se sont exprimés autour de ce
thème j'ai quelques scrupules à y
revenir car vous avez largement éclairer
le débat madame la ministre
mais si la convergence de ces questions
est réel je crois que cela montre bien
la prégnance de la difficulté sur nos
territoires et moi je voudrais insister
sur le rôle central que la gynécologie
médicale joue en matière de prévention
que ce soit par exemple sur le champ des
cancers gynécologiques
cela a été dit par mon collègue du tarn
et garonne que ce soit sur celui des ivg
dont on voit qu'elles sont en
augmentation préoccupante sur un certain
nombre de territoires le mien le
département du doubs n'échappe pas à
cette réalité
alors je crois que du coup il convient
de voir comment pallier à ces inégalités
territoriales et j'avais prévu une
double question d'abord madame la
ministre quelle analyse faites vous vous
même de la situation territoriale et
deuxièmement mais vous y avez déjà
largement répondu quelle politique
envisagez-vous pour permettre à nos
concitoyens car tel est l'enjeu
d'accéder dans des conditions renouveler
d'équité au service de gynécologie
médicale je vous remercie
merci avant la ministre de la santé
c'est le président monsieur le sénateur
claude jeannerot le fait est que les
gynécologues médical constitue une
spécialité de médecins de premier
recours auxquels les femmes doivent
pouvoir accéder dans des conditions
satisfaisantes et géographique et
financière les femmes de 19 à 69 ans
consultent en moyenne
en moyenne cela cache évidemment des
disparités importantes consultent en
moyenne un gynécologue une fois tous les
18 mois et il s'agit de faire en sorte
que l'accès aux médecins soient
facilitées en particulier pour faire
face aux enjeux de la prévention que
vous avez bien souligner et qui sont une
exigence dans notre pays dans le débat
qui a lieu en ce moment et qui a eu lieu
de façon extrêmement vives sur la
contraception l'accès à la contraception
la nature et la qualité de la
contraception
on voit bien que la possibilité pour les
femmes d'échanger de dialoguer de
discuter avec leur médecin est un
facteur tout à fait importante
prise en compte de leurs risques
personnels de leurs antécédents médicaux
parce que je leur ai dit si je profite
de la tribune qui m'est donnée pour le
faire dans le débat sur la pilule que
nous connaissons actuellement
nous devons être attentifs à ne pas
remettre en cause le principe même de la
contraception
il faut réaffirmer qu'il faut rester
avec sa contraception et que le risque
d'une grossesse non désirée ne doit pas
être pris pour en raison des skis et 10
sur la pilule pour autant la relation
avec le médecin permet de lever les
doutes et les inquiétudes chez les
femmes sur l'adaptation ou le caractèr
adapté de la contraception qui leur a
été prescrit
compte tenu de leurs antécédents
médicaux de leur histoire de leur
parcours de vie et de leur projet de vie
et donc je suis attaché à ce que partout
sur notre territoire les femmes puissent
accéder à un médecin un gynécologue
médical la lah les femmes sont toutes en
moyenne à moins de trente minutes d'un
gynécologue médicale en revanche les
délais d'accès à la consultation en
terme de temps pour avoir une
consultation sont importants et pour
cela la mise en place du pacte
territoire santé qui doit nous permettre
de renforcer la médecine de proximité
dans l'ensemble des territoires en
particulier les territoires ruraux
concerne bien évidemment aussi la
gynécologie médicale
le syndrome merci madame la ministre des
désespérances et des assurances que vous
voulez bien nous donner notamment au
travers du pacte territoire santé je me
rappelle qu'ici même dans cette enceinte
et au delà des critiques de fond que
nous avions formulées sur le texte de
loi hôpital patients santé territoires
nous avions fortement regretté que ce
texte qui se voulait fondateurs ne porte
pas un volet important de santé publique
car la prévention dont vous avez décrit
les exigences précisément constitue un
élément essentiel et majeur de cette
santé publique
merci de l'avoir souligné et merci
de nous en garantir l'effectivité pour
l'avenir merci la parole est à madame
catherine procaccia pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je vous remercie des réponses
que vous concrètes que vous avez apporté
déjà à mes collègues équipe ans
satisfont la plupart des groupes et un
certain nombre de nos visiteurs
l'accroissement du numerus clausus est
satisfaisant puisque vous porter à 35
postes en 2013 et à 45 en 2016 mais 45
postes ne fait qu'un poste de
gynécologues pour moins de deux
départements vous avez avec justesse
évoqué aussi la situation des villes qui
est aussi préoccupante que celle des
campagnes dans mon département il n'y a
plus que 36 gynécologue actuellement ans
il n'y en aura que 29 en 2017 alors je
me suis j'ai fait un petit ratio dans
mon département du val de marne qui est
celui aussi de madame cohen
compte tenu du nombre de femmes de plus
de 15 ans ça veut dire que chaque cas
gynécologue devrait recevoir 60 5
patientes par jour ouvré dans l'année et
non les recevants qu'une seule fois à
d'autant plus que la moyenne d'âge est
très élevée puisqu'elle est de 59 ans et
on n'a pas un seul gynécologue de moins
de 50 ans donc ce qui fait que la
situation du val de marne pour moi
demeure préoccupante parce que dans
cette répartition territoriale
comment elle est en nous dans le val de
marne pouvoir faire face à la demande à
laquelle on ne répond déjà pas à l'heure
actuelle mais surtout ma deuxième
préoccupation concerne les jeunes filles
qui sont très nombreuses vous le savez
nous avons répondu rendu un rapport au
sénat sur la santé et la sécurité
sociale
des étudiantes les sims propose des
consultations avec beaucoup de succès
puisque 50% des consultations sont des
consultations de gynécologie
lorsque les soupçons des centres de
soins puis ce qui n'est pas le cas de
celui de créteil et les étudiants
doivent donc se tourner vers le secteur
privé
est ce simplement selon amélie un quart
des gynécologues médicaux sont en
secteur 1 et 10 % ne prennent pas la
carte vitale
donc dans notre rapport nous avons
préconisé que soit appliqué des tarifs
opposables pour certaines spécialités
pour les étudiants dont les gynécologues
je voulais savoir madame la ministre si
vous comptez suivre nos recommandations
madame marisol touraine madame la
sénatrice
j'entends bien les préoccupations que
vous exprimez comme elles se sont
exprimées sur tous les bancs sur les
perspectives de démographie médicale
dans le dos de démographie dans le
domaine de la gynécologie médicale
pour autant je veux dire qu' il ne
s'agit pas de considérer que toutes les
femmes souhaiteront voudront ou auront
besoin d'accéder à un gynécologue
médical quand vous faites les ratios en
disant il faudrait que le nombre de
consultations par jour soit absolument
démesuré pour pouvoir faire face aux
besoins de la population c'est sans
compter le fait que des femmes peuvent
aller consulter une sage femme un
médecin généraliste un autre spécialiste
pour faire face à la situation qui est
la leur le deuxième point sur lequel je
veux insister que vous avez vous même
soulevé c'est qu'effectivement dans la
spécialité de gynécologie médicale
la proportion de médecins qui sont en
secteur 2 et qui pratiquent des
dépassements d'honoraires est très
importante
il ne s'agit pas de stigmatiser il ne
s'agit pas de mettre à l'index mais de
constater et je souhaite donc la
dynamique positive qui s'engagera dans
la suite de la négociation sur l'avenant
8 permettra dans le domaine de la
gynécologie médicale comme dans d'autres
de permettre un accès plus facile du
moins pour des raisons financières qui
ne sont pas les seules raisons à prendre
en considération mais qui existe un
accès plus facile donc de toutes les
femmes à un gynécologue
médical pour le reste je crois que le
rapport que vous avez évoqué fait des
propositions intéressantes et utiles
auquel nous devons réfléchir ensemble
face aux enjeux tels qu'ils existent de
meilleure prise en charge des jeunes
filles de meilleure prise en charge des
femmes ayant une contraception de
meilleure adaptation la contraception à
la diversité des situations des femmes
face aux défis posés par la démographie
je crois que nous devons ensemble et
sans a priori
essayez d'aller de l'avant et de trouver
les solutions qui pour chaque territoire
répondent le mieux aux situations
données
merci madame progrès siens madame la
ministre
il n'était pas question pour moi de
stigmatiser les médecins mais de dire
qu'effectivement pour les jeunes filles
pour les étudiants il ya un véritable
problème et le problème de la vence des
soins et en particulier dans des
territoires comme les miens où il ya
essentiellement des spécialistes en
secteur 2 et la santé des étudiants et
je le sais aussi une de vos
préoccupations donc l'accès facile doit
effectivement être une de nos
préoccupations
sachez que par rapport j'ai fait aussi
les calculs et les rations par rapport
aux gynécologues obstétriciens dans mon
département
ils sont 47 ils ont une moyenne d'âge
qui est équivalente légèrement
inférieure à celle des gynécologues
médicaux et la situation selon les
projections du cnom sont aussi
inquiétante dans un secteur que dans
l'autre mais je vous remercie d'avoir
signalé que dans un secteur urbain les
difficultés était aussi importante et il
faudrait effectivement pouvoir en tenir
compte
merci la parole et à madame catherine de
roche pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre le constat est là et tous les
intervenants précédents l'on dit
l'exercice de la gynécologie médicale se
heurte à une difficulté qui est le
manque de praticiens
vous avez répondu aux interrogations sur
votre volonté d'augmenter nombre de
postes d'un terne ouvert à cette
spécialité
j'ajouterai également toutes les
formations post internat en clinique à
et et en praticiens hospitaliers
notamment si on veut poursuivre la
formation des futurs internes mais je
souhaiterais pour ma part abordé la
notion de partage des tâches vous
l'avais un peu évoquée dans vos réponses
cet argument a souvent été évoqué par le
passé pour justifier le blocage des
ouvertures de postes
certes les médecins généralistes peuvent
assurer la prise en charge des patientes
même si la formation n'est pas
totalement équivalente mais sur le plan
pratique on sait et l'insuffisance du
nombre des généralistes et la réduction
leur temps d'activité effective qu'en
100 % des gynécologues médicaux font des
frottis seuls 10 % des médecins
généralistes en pratique certes des
gynécologues obstétriciens abandonnent
leurs activités chirurgicales et
d'accouchement pour réaliser des actes
médicaux
mais pourquoi après des années d'études
de spécialités chirurgicales font-ils ce
choix souvent pour des raisons de
conditions de travail et de poids de la
responsabilité civile et il conviendrait
d'ailleurs de s'attarder sur ses raisons
certes les sages-femmes dans le cadre de
la loi hpst ont vu leur champ de
compétences élargies mais sans nier leur
professionnalisme je rappelle qu'elles
ne sont pas médecins
les événements récents montrent par
exemple que la prescription de pilule un
acte médical non anodin qui doit tenir
une place majeure dans la discipline de
gynécologie médicale et je n'évoquerai
pas le cas des pharmaciens ou des
infirmières or en termes de santé
publique le besoin du suivi de la femme
sur le plan gynécologique et dans sa
globalité et de la jeune fille pubère
voire même pré pubères à la femme âgée
qui est souvent oubliée dans les
consultations gynécologiques où les
consultations des médecins généralistes
sur dans ce domaine là méritent toute
notre attention
j'en veux pour preuve le rapport récent
de la cour des comptes sur la
la vaccination est contre le
papillomavirus la cour des comptes
oppose le coût de la vaccination des
jeunes filles avec le dépistage organisé
systématique
encore faut-il pouvoir organiser ce
dépistage et assurer un suivi régulier
ce qui est le rôle des gynécologues
médicaux
madame la ministre ma question est donc
la suivante quelle est votre vision de
la délégation des tâches en ce domaine
et puis j'ajouterai une question
d'actualité puisque on a évoqué vous
l'avez évoqué vous même les pilules la
position prise d'un déremboursement de
la pilule diane sens en retrait du mythe
du marché peut être assez peu lisible
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
ce point madame la ministre marisol
touraine
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice catherine de roche je veux
répondre à aux deux grandes
interrogations que vous avez posé de la
manière suivante sont les transferts de
tâches attention d'ailleurs au mot
puisque en l'occurrence je les dis je
suis tout à fait favorable à ce que nous
organisions des parcours de soins et que
une femme comme d'ailleurs pour d'autres
spécialités et l'ensemble de la
population mais que la en l'espèce une
femme puisse être suivi par différents
spécialistes si elle en a besoin ou
différentes catégories de professionnels
de façon fluide les sages femmes ne sont
pas des professionnels
ara médical mais elles font bien partie
des professions médicales identifié
comme tel même si ce ne sont pas des
médecins mais donc j'insiste sur la
spécialité qui existe et qui est reconnu
par nos textes aux sages femmes
elle joue un rôle tout à fait important
le deuxième élément sur lequel je veux
insister c'est que qu'il s'agisse des
jeunes ou des moins jeunes puisque les
femmes doivent être suivies et prises en
charge à tous les âges de leur vie avec
des problématiques des sujets à prendre
en considération qui évidemment évolué
depuis la première contraception jusqu'à
la prévention du cancer du sein qui doit
être tout à fait appuyer et est maintenu
y compris pour les femmes plus âgées
puisqu'on sait que le risque est alors
accrue quel que soit l'âge de la vie il
est important pour les femmes de pouvoir
compter sur le bon conseil au bon moment
et de ce point de vue là je veux
insister sur le sujet de la
contraception que vous avez évoquées il
y a deux sujets différents qu'il
convient de bien distinguer la pilule de
3e et 4e génération d'un côté l'a dit
35 de l'autre des mesures de nature
différente ont été prises la diane 35
n'est pas considérée dans notre pays
comme un contraceptif puisque c'est un
médicament contre l'acné qui a été
utilisé en dehors de son autorisation de
mise sur le marché comme contraceptif
cette pilule sera retiré suspendu donc
retiré du marché jusqu'à ce qu'une
décision européenne nous oriente quant à
la façon de déterminer la prescription
éventuelle à l'avenir de ce médicament
pour les autres pilules de 3ème enfin
pour les autres médicaments pilule de 3e
et 4e génération
le déremboursement ne renvoie pas à une
analyse du risque mais renvoie au fait
que ces pilules ne représente pas
davantage médicale par rapport aux
pilules de deuxième génération et donc
il n'est pas utile que la collectivité
les prennent en charge
il appartient aux médecins en relation
avec sa patiente de déterminer la bonne
contraception au bon moment
madame la ministre la dame de roche vous
avez trente secondes pour respecter le
temps global qui nous est imparti
oui je voulais remercier madame la
ministre en effet il est important de
clarifier parce qu'on lit beaucoup de
choses sur sur ces pilules et il
importait qu'on ait cette clarification
que vous avez donné même si sur les
pilules de troisième génération
on nous a dit qu'elle était quel pouvoir
des indications très précises sur le
plan médical et qui aurait peut-être
justifiée dans ce cas là un
remboursement
je vous remercie mes chers collègues je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h pour la suite de l'examen
de la proposition de loi adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture visant à préparer la transition
vers à soie pour cette séance de
questions cribles consacrée aujourd'hui
à la gynécologie médicale séance au
cours de laquelle la ministre de la
santé marisol touraine indiqué au
sénateur qu'elle allait relever
le numerus clausus pour le porter à 45
gynécologues médicaux d'ici à 2020 si
vous souhaitez revoir cette séance de
questions cribles elle est disponible en
vod dès maintenant sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
de journée à tous